here for reaction fox news contributor
joe concha along with cpac chair
matt schlapp two friends of ours joe let
me start with you it is a it's a mess
and not getting better and now they're
starting to talk about it to their
buddies in the media
yeah pete first that that stat on 70
people having to manage social media
accounts i mean how does that work on
your average day hey who's got it today
number 14 no i think 32 has it actually
69 has i mean 70 people
i mean boy give me that job you probably
don't have to work all that much but but
look dysfunction in this white house is
not a recent development as described in
these stories it has existed for nearly
a year since afghanistan fell to the
taliban and somehow no one saw that
coming and my main takeaway pete from
these pieces is that the white house
simply believes that it has a messaging
problem which it does but in the end
people really don't care about rhetoric
they care about results and the results
16 months in this administration are
horrific i mean inflation is almost six
times higher than it was when donald
trump left office six times gas prices
have increased 100 since this president
took office crime continues to spiral
out of control criminals are more brazen
than ever because they know if they get
arrested there's a good chance they'll
be back out on the street quickly and
the crisis that is a catastrophe at the
border only gets worse all while
fentanyl that is primarily coming in
through the u.s southern border is
killing americans at an unprecedented
rate so there is no cute hashtag or
bumper sticker that's that spins all
this into convincing people everything
is really a-okay voters see what they
see they feel what they feel
increasingly it's clear pete that the
adults are not back in the room
no it's true uh matt i don't know how
many people manage your account over
there at cpac but i do know uh
under donald trump it was prob it was
only donald trump and maybe dan scavino
maybe two people on social media now
it's up to 70. but but that raises kind
of my next question is this a policy
problem matt is this a potus problem or
is this a democrat party problem where
they have gone so far left and joe's in
that box he's got 70 people around and
making sure whatever comes out of count
is right down the line he can't change
if he wants to but obviously this is the
house that he's built
well unfortunately it's the whole ball
of wax therapy you have a candidate or a
president who's simply not up to the job
he doesn't have the physical vitality to
do the job they don't tell him things
that are happening because my guess is
he's not in that office all day long and
so they have to kind of pick their
moments when he's
ready to hear something and they never
gelled as a team because of zoom and
doom and their fear over getting sick
with this virus and all that panic he
was elected president without running a
real campaign and having a real
operation where people bond i've been on
those presidential campaigns and you
really bond when you're getting attacked
and you see that you can work together
as a team they don't seem to have that
it starts right with kamala harris the
other thing that i find astounding is
how quickly they proved
that socialism is a cancer in our
country you know they usually get away
with trying to spend more to solve
problems and blaming republicans for
things like shootings and stuff and they
get away with that because of all their
allies in the media the problem is is
that all of these policies have
compounded to this out of control
inflation that it seems like there's
nothing they can do because they always
want to spend more to solve it um and uh
combine that uh with the fact that our
energy prices which is part of inflation
has everybody panicked about what
they're what's going to happen with
their jobs and let's let's bring up one
last thing we're not even back to the
employment rates something like half a
million jobs shy of where we were before
the pandemic so they can tell us that
everything's great but we're not even
where we were before the pandemic and
the american people aren't stupid
no they're not uh joe the white house
press corps famously and we see this you
saw it under obama you say the way they
went after trump you see the way they
they with kid gloves treated biden but
for these stories to start coming out
it's even it's it's one thing for fox
news to to to tell the story it's
another thing for dc insider
publications to start talking about not
just dysfunction but chaos
yeah it's we follow sports pretty
closely pete right and you see this when
teams that were supposed to be pretty
good going into a season suddenly things
go south in a hurry and everybody starts
pointing fingers and running to the
press telling you what players are the
problems or what coaches of the problems
and that's what's happening now
everybody's pointing fingers because
they don't want to be blamed but the
writing is on the wall clearly and it's
very apparent to this white house that
they're about to suffer in historic
shellacking to matt's point in the
november midterms i mean this is an
administration that is viewed as
incompetent and slow to react to crises
and this view extends to more than a few
democrats as well and and here you have
more than a few in in media who seem
surprised that we are where we are under
this president because in their zest to
get rid of the former president and
trump they didn't bother to look very
much at the guy who replaced him and has
failed upwards his entire career pete so
yeah and and focusing on trump no one
really took a good look at biden and
just how decision after decision he has
made whether it be foreign policy or
domestic have not been good ones he
doesn't have the instincts clearly
it's true matt last word real quick
yeah i know this is the a real problem
that the bite administration has is that
the reason why they can't get out of
this hole is because there's no way to
get out of the hole they can't use the
president they can't use the vice
president their policies suck and
they're going to get killed in the
midterms and i think the democratic
party is going to be seen as a left
leaning party much like labor was in the
uk and it could be a long way back for
them which i'm actually pretty happy
about
yup me too
i like that analysis uh matt schlapp joe
concha thank you both appreciate it have
a great night hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else